Fox News Alert President Biden just
reacting to a damning special counsel
report on his handling of classified
documents a report that called him an
elderly man with a poor memory the
special councel released their findings
today about their look into my handling
of classified documents I was pleased to
see they reached the conclusion I
believed and knew all along they would
that there are no charges should be
brought in this
case
as many of you know this was an
exhaustive investigation going back
literally more than 40 years 40 years
when I became a United States Senator I
was a
kid I was a kid 29 years old bottom line
is the special counsel in my case
decided against moving forward with any
charges this matter is now closed the
special Council releasing his long
awaited classified documents report
Robert her is his name and he is not
recommending criminal charges but he
laid out how the president willfully
retained and disclosed highly classified
materials when he was a private citizen
including sensitive National Security
matters and documents about military and
foreign policy in Afghanistan and as the
White House feared the report is full of
embarrassing details including these
dramatic photos of tattered boxes in Joe
Biden's Delaware garage right next to
the Corvette the sensitive files were
stored quote near a collapsed dog crate
a dog bed a zapo box an empty bucket a
broken lamp wrapped with duct tape
potting soil and synthetic firewood but
remember when Biden told you that
everything was Secure classified
material next to your Corvette what were
you
thinking let me uh we I'm going to get a
chance to speak on all this God willing
soon but as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvette's in a
lock garage okay so it's not like you're
sitting out in the street but anyway was
a locked garage yes as well as my
Corvette um but as I said earlier this
week people know I take classified
documents and classified material
seriously they discovered a small number
of documents of classified markings in
storage areas and file cabinets in my
home the special council is also
painting a devastating picture about the
president's mental acuity with this
quote we have also considered that at
trial Mr Biden would likely present
himself to a jury as he did during our
interview of him as a sympathetic
well-meaning elderly man with a poor
memory it would be difficult to convince
a jury that they should convict him by
then a former president well into his
80s of a serious felony that requires a
mental state of willfulness and that
wasn't the only instance of the special
counsel bringing up Biden's significant
limitations when it comes to memory the
President also could not recall the
years that he was vice president or when
his son Bo died
uh president Trump has issued a
statement team here I'll read it for you
he said they should immediately drop the
case against me I am covered by the
presidential records act he wasn't he
had many many times more documents
totally unguarded M were always
surrounded by secret service and in
locked rooms and Biden also made some
more comments between about a
distinction between him and Trump listen
here I was especially pleased to see the
special counsel make clear the Stark
differences between this case and Donald
Trump as a special councel wrote and I
quote several material distinctions
between Mr Trump's case and Mr Biden are
clear and by the way this is the
Republican Council most
notably after given multiple chances
special Council acknowledge I cooperated
completely I did not throw up any
roadblocks I sought no
delays okay so we can talk about the
merits of the case but I think that the
most devastating thing that I've seen in
this campaign so far is from the special
counsil on mental acuity and I Greg will
turn it over to you but want to put put
up this Poll for everyone just to remind
you the NBC poll from this week asked a
question does Trump or Biden have the
necessary mental and physical health to
be president and only 23% of those
pulled said Biden had that mental
capacity so over to you remember how
hard the media pushed the 25th Amendment
yes now here it is MH what do you do
when it's your guy clearly there's
evidence of severe memory loss confusion
mental impairment what are you waiting
for for the poor guy to wander down
Pennsylvania Avenue and nothing but a
shower cap we thought Harvard had
diminished faculties they aren't just
talking by the way about your kindly
neighbor who forgets where he is and
he's wandering on your front lawn in an
open robe we're talking about the leader
of the Free World right you know they're
comp they're describing him as an
elderly man with a poor memory that
doesn't possess a mental state of of
willfulness I mean this is not Gramps
with onset dementia this is the
president of the United States he has
the keys to the nuclear football I can
only hope that he doesn't know or
remember where it is but this is like I
mean it's to quote morisy the joke isn't
funny anymore it's now really real they
told us something we already knew and
it's something that the media can't spin
right he's mentally they basically said
he's mentally unfit to stand trial that
is a naked assessment I mean he's we've
seen him uh refer to dead people as if
they're alive he can't do simple
interviews in the Super Bowl he's
declining faster than his poll numbers
and it's I think at this point
something's going to happen I'm
beginning to think so too and I had not
been in that thinking that way mostly
except for when Jesse asked me to
comment if Michelle Obama's going to be
stepping in uh I do wonder if Jesse
since they had an idea the White House
had an idea that this was coming for a
while that it was one of the main
reasons they decided to decline the
opportunity to do that Super Bowl
interview because he would have had to
been asked about it that would have been
the first question at the Super Bowl
interview and then he comes out today
and says case is closed and then he says
I became president to bring red States
and green States together yeah and he
says he wants to bring back Ro V versus
Ward and this is two days after he says
I saw dead people M twice M he's saying
he's meeting with people that have been
dead for 30 years by the way look at the
garage does this look like the garage of
a president of the United States or does
this look like your grandfather's
packrat
garage that is not the way you organize
your life as a president there's a
broken lamp with duct tape next to
classified documents they actually had
to move the files to a different box cuz
the thing you couldn't even pick it up
it would fall apart there's like Dusty
golf clubs
shoe boxes and hunters in and out of
there with God knows who come on so they
said this guy willfully retained
classified documents that put our
national security at risk because it was
in an unsecure
location but you couldn't ever get a
conviction at trial because he's an
elderly man with memory issues and he
didn't really know what he was doing
because he's got diminished faculties so
this is the same thing they do with
Hillary Hillary definit broke the law
and they laid out about a dozen times
how she did it but then they list about
half the report about why we're not
going to bring charges they did the same
thing with him it's another beautiful
offramp but remember what they did to
marako they had pictures of beautifully
organized stack boxes in a ballroom and
the media says how dare Donald Trump
mishandle classified documents like that
and CNN to this point before we came on
the air they haven't even put up the
garage photos yeah they haven't even put
it out there did you know that the ghost
writer who he shared classified
documents with destroyed the tapes when
he found out there was a special counsil
investigation so the minute he hears
they being under investigation for
mishandling classified documents the guy
deletes all of the tapes of Joe Biden
and then they're not going to charge him
of course but they have Joe Biden on
tape and I would love to hear these
tapes because Joe Biden's on tape saying
yeah are classified and he's sharing
classified information with his Ghost
Writer it's what David Petraeus got
popped for it's the exact same thing and
then they're saying this guy's painfully
slow significant limitations struggles
to remember events straining at times to
read and relate his own notes this was
seven years ago we're now seven years
after the fact and we're talking not
only 25th amendment we're talking about
you might have to bow out because the
crescendo now is going to grow so large
of not just the people in The Press Corp
but other Democrats are going to see
this and they're going to read this and
they say how can you do this to this guy
because right now this was a devastating
body blow to the reelection campaign no
matter how they want to spin it this was
bad can you imagine being the press
secretary thinking about that briefing
tomorrow I don't think there will be one
I might call in sick judge
um I wonder
talk about the White House's response to
Robert her saying that the comments
about mental acuity are Superfluous and
unnecessary and that they said that they
weren't and that they're not true and
they want they wanted Robert her to take
them out wait okay so you can't have it
both ways the comments are not true but
the conclusion they came to to not
indict uh Joe Biden is accurate and to
the point let me tell you something this
report is worse than an indictment
this report demands the 25th Amendment
and here's my Constitution this man
needs to be thrown out of office and
there's another point the fact that they
talked about the fact that he's an old
man with a poor memory seven years ago
that he's sharing classified documents
at a time when he's not even president
Donald Trump was President this guy was
in possession of documents as a senator
as a vice president he had no right to
have that information sharing it with
his Ghost Writer sharing it I'm sure
with the editor the editor would not
have published a book without making
sure that everything in that book didn't
have backup I've written eight books I
know that and then they say well he also
showed a letter from Kim Jong o to Bob
Woodward uh in the Oval Office
everything about this tells and shows
the American people how there are two
separate systems of justice and this is
where my prosec U comes through if you
get to the point where you say no jury
will convict this guy because he is
non-comp MST because he does not have
the mental capacity to form the intent
that means you've already gotten to the
point where you believe he should be
indicted but you're not indicting him
because you don't believe the jury will
find him competent to stand trial this
is the worst thing that can happen to
Joe Biden and let me say one more thing
about that when they made the decision
to not
indict they still could have indicted
him the way they indicted Donald Trump
for Espionage the Espionage charges that
Donald Trump is under by crazy Jack
Smith don't involve intent or
willfulness they involve gross
negligence so if you want to tell me Joe
Biden can't formulate intent he cannot
formulate uh a a willfulness if then for
sure you can get him for gross
negligence explain to me Mr her why
there is a difference there and this
indictment against Donald Trump for a
number of reasons and I don't want to
hog their time should be dismissed based
upon the joke that this whole thing is
Harold want to hear everything you have
to say but I want set it up this way so
the special council is saying that Biden
is too old and incompetent to be held
responsible for mishandling classified
information and state secret and Biden
is saying I am not too old and I am not
competent and I want four more years as
the leader of the Free World I mean how
is that supposed to go
over so uh this is a tough day for the
White House and for President Biden I
think two things and I think uh the
judge said some of it uh and basically
everyone everyone has said things that I
agree with I don't agree disagree with a
whole lot the thing for me is what Mr
HST said that he willfully retained the
documents which uh on the Trump matter
has been the predicate for why charges
were brought so if you believe he will
hopefully retain the documents but your
argument uh M the president's argument
President Biden's argument is that I
cooperated fully with him and then uh
president Trump did not if indeed that
is the case and it looks like that could
be the case least what we're reading in
the public narrative then maybe
president Trump should have been charged
with only obstruction of justice exactly
uh and may not should have been charged
with with the the handling of the
documents this case here and the way it
has been handled will certainly give
more Credence to that argument uh but we
can't ignore the politics the politics
are infused with the the legal part of
it and it's certainly infused with with
the second part which is Mr H's
conclusion that if he took this before
jury that Mr Biden might seem
sympathetic because he's an older fell
with diminished memory uh the White
House is pushing back on that it is
going to be difficult to push back on
that I judge I I agree with agree with
your your your statement there at end
reconciling the two I was I'm too old
and my memory is too slight for me to be
prosecuted it uh but I should get four
more years which is what Dana said this
is a uh a complicated it's a complicated
piece for the president but I think if a
legal standpoint I think the question
becomes um for president Trump uh we're
talking about President here former
president Trump why was he charged if he
willfully retained the documents and
President Biden was not um and if the
reason is because president Trump I get
the reason if he didn't cooperate and he
told people not to cooperate that would
seem to me to be an obstruction charge
uh but I just play a lawyer on the
people might remember this from 60
minutes this is when Biden talked about
Trump being
irresponsible how that could possibly
happen how one anyone could be that
irresponsible and I thought what data
was in there that may compromise sources
and methods by that I mean names of
people who helped or Etc and it just uh
totally irresponsible
Greg maybe he didn't remember that he
had it too yeah well it's it's part of
that pattern it's like they they always
blame the Republicans or anybody for
what they're actually doing uh but I
hear Biden is he he's fine he just spoke
to Ruth Bader
Ginsburg and she told him he can't be
tried so that's good news that's good
news um I I also kind of I find this a
bit aist as somebody who was young that
means if I commit a crime I can't say
that I have age related mental cognitive
difficulties don't you find that wrong
it's unfair that he gets that defense
and I don't maybe inite five more years
believe you you can offer that yeah the
other thing too is this could be related
his decline could be related to Trump
derangement syndrome there might be an
actual biological underpinning that when
your brain is uh focused on an obsessive
thought for a period of years than the
other parts of your brain atrophies
you're seeing this a lot with people
with TDS they're like they're they're
failing in their jobs and their
relationships because they become
overcome with Trump what do you think
the Democrats are actually thinking now
behind closed doors I I can imagine what
do you think Gavin Newsome's thinking
right now or even KLA Harris well I
don't want to say what Gavin Newsome's
thinking right now because it's
dirty but if I were a Democrat I'd
probably know that this was already
happening it's been whispered about
everybody knows this is what this thing
here what judge says is so devastating
this is what they've been trying to hide
for three years and so Robert H spends
two days with the president let's just
say five to six hours total that's more
time than any reporter in three years
has ever spent with the president it's
more time than we've ever really seen
the president could you imagine Brett
Bear or let's just say Greg Gutfeld
sitting down with Joe Biden for five 5
hours and asking him questions about
policy and his performance well her did
it and the conclusion was the man has
diminished
faculties this is the biggest insight
you're going to get about the president
from anybody in a non partisan way
forget about the fact that he's a
republican he gave the guy six off ramps
to not get indicted but he's arguing
about the classified he goes I get to
keep these things because they're mine
these are mine every other president's
got to take stuff home it's the same
argument Donald Trump said except he's
not president he's on tape arguing no no
this is this isn't this is classified
but I'm going to keep it you can't this
guy comes across as a small
sloppy and mentally unfit man and I bet
a lot of the people around the world are
looking at this report saying oh my God
right I about that
to everybody's seeing this right so I
think that's also why the White House
was like you don't that they're telling
her don't include this because it's
Superfluous but our adversaries our en
our enemies the troops see it
everybody's seeing it well you know the
truth is that it's not as though they
actually needed this everybody's been
seeing it for the last few years but
that is
confirmation of what we all have been
saying and what our foreign leaders
suspected and whenever jeanpierre or the
president get a tough question they say
you know as Biden said everybody knows I
take classified documents seriously or
she'll say everybody knows America's
back they never answer any questions the
president is incapable seven years ago
he didn't know when he was uh vice
president when his term started when it
ended six months ago he didn't know when
his son died and we are giving this man
the ability to be the commanderin-chief
of the greatest nation on earth when he
is inep and let me just say one thing
Jesse at least Donald Trump had Secret
Service uh in terms of those documents
that he had as president he also had
them in locked rooms as President Joe
Biden took them when he knew full well
as a senator he wasn't supposed to take
him out of a skiff he wasn't supposed to
take notes and then he says I didn't
know Harold can I ask
you I mean let's be hon don't aren't the
Democrats going to have like secret
cabal meeting to say like what are we
going to do we cannot have him at the
top of the ticket I don't know what what
the party party will do I do know let me
speak say two things first um I agree
with what I I I firmly believe what I
said earlier that the willfully
retaining of the documents there's a
question about about both of these CA
this cases one is being treated one way
one being treated another way it's going
to behoove Mr Smith and perhaps someone
at the justice department or both to
remind the American people again what
are the differences between these cases
and why was one charge and why was not
uh two we are living in a time we have
two the two leading candidates for
president both parties both parties
believe that they're too old to be
president if a majority of them do we
like new people we now have to the
judge's point to the point been made
around the table we now have an
independent verification for someone who
chose not to bring legal charges against
the president citing strongly I've not
read all of the document but citing
strongly is one of the reasons that the
president's memory and mental faculties
are would be a favor for him in trial
and he would appeal to the jury and he
didn't want to indict him for or indict
him is the wrong thing but didn't want
to bring charges or recommend charges
for that reason so this is something
again I the justice department and the
special prosecutor on the other side Mr
Smith I think just because the country
is so imil and engaged with this is
going to have to explain again the
differences between these two Cas I
think it's the worst two weeks since the
Afghanistan situation in terms of his
presidency you've had a week of
immigration and that's the worst thing
he's known for yep and then you're now
going to get into a week-long discussion
of the Democrats saying the president is
not mentally deficient okay and the
polling he already bottomed out at 33%
and he's down six to Trump and now you
have quotes here's a quote when did I
stop being vice president yeah or
another quote am I still Vice President
in 2009 those are direct quotes from the
president this man is the president
that's hard you just imagine if if if
this was a report about Donald Trump I
think it was they just made it up right
the 25th Amendment stuff all right hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe
right now